some Asian karaoke you might be
wondering why I'm dancing like this at
an Iranian nightclub in Los Angeles let
me explain
my name is yaara no not that Yara the
half black half Iranian actress I'm a
different yarn but like her I'm also
Iranian American my parents immigrated
from Iran and settled in Northern
California where I was born and raised
but even though I've been in the States
pretty much my whole life I've always
felt sort of in-between meaning both
American and well Iranian this is
especially true now Iran they terrorist
nation like few others as attempts have
been made to ban Iranians and other
Middle Easterners from entering the u.s.
a complete shutdown of Muslims entering
the United States it'd be our people we
are not the government and I'm gonna
turn on you Dalia I've been made very
aware of my Iranian identity all this
got me thinking what does it mean to be
both Iranian and American and is this
the first time we've had to deal with
something like this to answer that I
decided to head to the world's largest
community of Iranians outside of Iran
which happens to be in Los Angeles or as
people here call it Tehran jealous
[Music]
a second traffic hey Siri where is
Tanner Angeles Siri was useless
so I asked irani an American writer poor
cheese - Huck poor who grew up in LA -
show me the symbolic center of the
Iranian community here Westwood
Boulevard also known as Persian Square
so we're basically entering her Angeles
now this is where the heart of it is
growing up poor chooses parents would
drive the family 40 minutes almost every
weekend to get to Westwood and imagine
that parents must have been very hard to
afford it but they wanted to have me be
in touch with the culture if you think
they're you're running out the hair
they're definitely running the whole
place is like a little slice of Iran in
America everything is written in Persian
also known as Farsi the official
language of Iran
you walk into stores and immediately
start speaking Persian there's tons of
Iranian people everywhere and Iranian
food I'm gonna eat this tongue sandwich
oh my god this is Iranian fruit leather
made in refrigerator and a kitchen is
all this stuff
there's even a shop that sells Iranian
music from your mother I mean Josh : I
am a dancer Angeles the monomer a little
bit too though dad almost uh it's
estimated there's about 1 million
Iranian Americans and about half of them
live in Southern California but why did
so many Iranians choose la I met up with
sociologist Ali Akbar Maddy to find out
he offered a few reasons number one the
weather in Los Angeles is very much like
Tehran it's war number two California is
the place where the communities that
exist here
Latinos Asians Arabs Iranians each of
them have their independent community an
immigrant could literally be who
I want to be and number three once a
group has come you're gonna have a base
and that begins to attract other people
this is now a largest community of
Iranian outside of Iran walking around
Tehran Julis I realized that a lot of
Iranians here called themselves Persian
unlike Porsha stunned me but why is that
Iran ian's like me like when we first
got to America everybody was saying
Persian everything the word Iran's
negative yeah it was horrible so out of
survival people like my parents and
their generation start saying Persian I
don't blame them you know you don't even
say that Iran Iran you see their vision
what did that first massive wave of
Iranian immigrants need to protect
themselves from the Iranians who
confronted the stereotypes and
prejudices after hostage crisis they
needed a protective shield and Persia
and Persian gave them that cover what
was the hostage crisis let me give you a
quick rundown
in 1979 Iranians had a revolution they
got rid of their American backed king
the Shah and established an Islamic
Republic led by this guy Ayatollah
Khomeini the Shah fled his country and
at one point went to the US for medical
treatment anti-shah students wanted the
United States to return him to Iran to
face trial so they broke into the
American Embassy in Tehran and took
dozens of American diplomats hostage 52
Americans were held for 444 days their
ordeal known as the hostage crisis
became a fixture of American TV news day
314 of the hostage crisis in Iran
nightly newscast showed the same images
over and over again burning American
flags fist-pumping Iranians and
blindfolded American hostages as a
result anti-iranian sentiments started
to seep into the American psyche
Iranians were demonized in books movies
and music
the hostage crisis also took a toll on
public opinion by 1980 some 60% of
Americans had a negative view of Iran
fast-forward to 1989 and that's
skyrocketed to 91% this hit especially
hard for porch ista whose family fled
Iran after the Revolution a time when
many other Iranians left the country
when she arrived in the u.s. she was
just a little kid Paris and then we got
to the u.s. I can't emphasize enough how
horrible when we got the u.s. in the
early 80s I mean I was so young but I
remember all of it vividly because I was
so traumatized by the atmosphere of
hatred in America I was just made fun of
constantly there was a lot of
anti-iranian sentiments and I would get
that on playgrounds
I heard dune boom there was sand and
words camel jockey camel jockey camel
jockey was you know that slur camel
jockey it was a predominant slur used
against people from Iran and possibly
the rest of the Middle East in the 80s
it was in that very political climate
that master shivani opened his ice cream
shop Mashti Malone's
his brother maybe joined him in 1988 and
helped expand the business the two are
often credited with bringing Persian ice
cream to LA Ginobili mash de Gallo's
Kenichi should borodin as they passed
initially chop-busting is happy business
that's our bestseller here start from
rosewater that's ginger rosewater and
then there is orange blossom with
pistachio bhajan orange this is the the
Persian falooda
but we mix that with sour cherry sour
cherry follow the is made of rose rose
water with rice starch noodles oh that
one's my favorite
okay I feel like I'm literally sitting
in my grandma's house right now mashney
Malone's a scene as an LA institution
now but when masty first opened his shop
in 1980 during the hostage crisis things
were not so easy for Iranians Maya's
dong Zhuo
there was a couple young American there
then they start punching me my chest
that go back to you at country but the
Chan Tobuscus Iran yellow banana Bucheon
judo Luna - for me too much you know
came on say hey you guys are in wrong
place you know even in stay more you
release them or Arab you know so that
time I got saved anti-iran protests were
happening all over the country from
Washington DC to Beverly Hills one of
them was even organized by California
State Senator I mean ever they could see
that the media was completely against
Iranians they kind of associated people
with the government so what were the
government did people here got punished
for it to all the Iranian students they
were afraid to see their Iranian mera
naam Chima Madame padamu even American
in Yemen touch them for the vaccinia
mood this is a giant container of
saffron you may get two of the saw my
god I don't think I've ever seen this
much saffron in one place in spite of
what happened to him during the hostage
crisis years mash he doesn't hold any
grudges Tommy Tommy Matta the dealer in
Jordan Turkey
the your ties is very necessary
Los Angeles film heliox no shotgun bow
in your toes if I send you off the dump
very sure you can't down this is the the
best temperatures to try ice creams you
can taste the cardamom in this thing
hi doctor to blame I was a bad sunny
food chef de barranca douche I mean bad
Stan you know matter fish gotta look
awesome gets it on your Dutch tuition
what I realized from mash T and matey is
that those who came before me
the people who established the Iranian
American community they went through a
lot I didn't have to deal with the
immediate fallout from the hostage
crisis and I'm thankful for that but me
and other second-generation Iranian
Americans have had to deal with
something else something that made us
feel like others in our own country hey
guys thanks for watching the first
episode of our four part series on
iranian americans don't forget to
subscribe to catch the next episode of
the series because there's breakdancing
rare iranian food and so much more